стефанчук і ко вбили контролюючу функцію
парламенту стефанчук і ко вбили свободу
слова в парламенті і я прошу моє зараз
виступ як депутатський запит оформити
тому що я хочу заявити про політичний
тиск і політичну сегрегацію на фракцію
європейська Солідарність і на мене як
співголову фракції з боку голови
Верховної Ради стефанчука і ко які вже
дев'ять місяців блокують
міжпарламентську діяльність мою як
співголови фракції європейська
Солідарність і представниці фракції
європейська Солідарність в
парламентській асамблеї ОБСЄ а також
моїх колег яким заблокована фактично
можливість міжпарламентського
спілкування в рамках PP і ми бачимо
найгірші практики часів Януковича На
жаль стефанчука і ко тичуть носом те що
відбувається в парламенті вже з брюсселю
це план Ukraine facility п'ята стаття
говорить про те що передумовою для
видання Україні надання нам допомоги 50
млрд євро є демократія є Парламентська
багатопартійність Ми подаруємо звичайно
зараз цей важливий документ стефанчуку і
ко аби вони з ним ознайомилися і
вважаємо що перетворювати парламент на
придаток банковий вбивати демократію
вбивати парламентаризм це найгірше що
можна робити для нашої майбутньої
Перемоги ми боремось з тоталітарною
державою і ми не повинні перетворюватись
на авторитарний режим вбиваючи
демократію і парламентаризм ми
категорично проти цього